all right check it in with ted now today
was
awfully nice i must say nice right last
week
of 2020 remember how chilly it was yes
this week though look at this
low 60s right now for our high for the
day today yesterday 59 so temperatures
warmed up today as we told you they
would 57
is our average so five above normal 40
for the overnight low now the question
is can we keep this going can we keep it
mild
as we go through the rest of this week
the answer coming up right now let's
start off with some neighborhoods
centennial hills at 55 right now for you
that's sky canyon
providence up there northwest part of
the valley summerlin 50 even the lakes
59
58 for aliante downtown north las vegas
coming in at 57 degrees we're
61 for green valley henderson 53 low
50's also for rhodes ranch
mountains edge and southern highlands
and currently 49 already
for anthem and seven hills double fours
are up there in cali any
prompt at 56 degrees 54 for boulder city
and also nice and mild
you're currently at 61. now here's our
satellite and radar
not getting any i mean really very few
clouds out there
of course we're not expecting any
rainfall so everything's staying dry
here even
the southern portions of the sierras
where the northern portions of this area
were actually getting some snow
yesterday now there are storms out there
out in pacific okay specifically out
near the aleutian islands and one after
the other
will be staying to the north if they
track south
then yeah we would increase some chances
for showers but these will all
stay and pivot to the north one thing we
will get from them however
no rainfall but we will see increased
wind in fact our wind cast
does show those winds pick up a little
on wednesday but then the bigger more
vigorous system that we'll be tracking
to the east of us
will actually increase our winds
saturday and sunday so those will be the
wind days on saturday and sunday
specifically and we'll also see a cool
down along with those winds too
monday maybe some light breezes around
but it's really the weekend that we're
watching and then also midweek next week
so if you plan to do some exercise in
the morning
a lot of people do guess what doesn't
look too bad tomorrow
fair conditions in the morning remember
this is going to be your low time this
is the time where
your overnight low will be around five
to six am right so we'll call it fair
but after that great exercise weather
from 8 a.m to beyond no alerts
have been issued for tomorrow forecast
overnight here you go 40 degrees clear
and chilly we'll see some clouds by
morning and we'll see those clouds mixed
in with sunshine tomorrow
60 will be our high winds will stay
light for the most part for tomorrow
your forecasted highs
neighborhood by neighborhood 58 in
centennial hills aliante 59 north las
vegas 59
and same goes for mountains edge 62 for
green valley 58 for
henderson sun and clouds through
thursday but temperatures stay mild
cooler this weekend with more wind
that's your most accurate weather update
denise over here